[Music]
in for the fans news for the fans
sunflora finance submitted by proud
one-pump chump
good for you Val oh that's kind of a
talent yeah I agree
I want to be able to do probably get a
lot of work done then yes potent at the
same time he just goes right into
bathroom
one pump Wow just a geyser he had you
join Minh pleasure
nah we don't care we just was a dope
rapper new milk one pump chop we just
want to shoot ropes
Demi Lovato will be offering free group
therapy sessions to fans on her 2018
tour what is she doing that news New Age
spiritual thingy well didn't she have
that website where she's selling like
[ __ ] glitter and crystal [ __ ] things
isn't it
what is a couple of our songs again I
know her name yeah I don't know where
songs either not really popular though
the shiny shiny choo-choo train one of
those things where it's like oh I don't
know her songs but like I know all our
songs like like Avril Lavigne this is
like Demi Lovato you got adult voice I'm
pretty sure how I can't even remember is
her group what is the group therapy
session that she's doing if it's a
circle jerk I'm gonna play this clip
here where she announced it on Good
Morning America why she looked different
what happened photo shop aru's she was
like hot and then she got fat is moving
here whereas it was a still before oh
but she's a great musician she's a great
musician pre musician for all the fans
out there
Wow Joe Vinick oh he's gonna be walking
that one back for the neck
ten minutes that's pretty [ __ ] tight
though dude like a st. next to you yeah
what I hope people learn from my story I
mean I make it my life going to talk
about other people I think that it's
important that I use my voice for more
than just singing mm-hmm and I I just
know how important it is to use my
platform to help me into recovery or
better themselves whatever it is I just
want people to know that all alone and
I'm here for them I think it's really
important to take away the stigma of
mental illness I actually have bipolar
disorder and I'm very open about that
because I think that mental health
affects so many people
well artists doesn't have much more away
from it the notion is we're actually
bringing cast on tour so we
[Applause]
sweet washer whenever I did the future
now tour we broadcast on tour and it's
basically a basically like a therapy
session before the concerts and we have
speakers from all over and we're also
helping out with different charities
from around the country so it'll be
incredible a very moving and inspiring
it I love it she's so awesome easy easy
easy
she does so much for the community and I
too late
I don't do [ __ ] yet like eight more
minutes to walk she's saving lives she's
spreading the word gonna be picking up
trash for the beach this weekend yeah
that's gonna be great by the way did I
mention she's very sexy yeah there you
go
yeah I'm sure she'll love that lovely
voice by the way you just called her fat
fat fat girls could be hot too I ain't
afraid am it I [ __ ] jacked off to
this one cam girl she was really on the
bigger side but she was hot as hell he
called the girl fat
and Betty text relator days I had jury
duty early ready it was a bad scene cuz
I was just jerking at tea and I blew a
load to you it's like worse because
that's like wow beautiful was this a
one-on-one game girl do you do that [ __ ]
no I don't pay for that oh I would
I wish you did I want to talk to one of
those guys that was it was like a her
and her boyfriend was like yeah so
there's a difference between like oh you
fat and like oh observation you're fat
that's what I'm saying like observation
skinny girl that makes sense observation
actually elbows are you saying are you
saying Demi Lovato you think she's no no
I just thought it was why do you think
that one's a measurement yeah the one or
the other one is an actual like
adjective I understand see one is fat
shaming and I don't do that
right because there's nothing there's
nothing shameful about that it's
actually something beautiful to it right
like this my girlfriend got a fat ass
and it was like oh yeah it's positive
right so possibly my lady has a fat ass
that's cool
but up but in this case it was just like
wow how does she go from this picture to
this picture in a matter of seconds that
was different for what courtesy this
will get interrogated it's over cuz I
feel like you're very misunderstood
usually it's Bart no it's not no I don't
know they need to translate themselves
no no she was saying you were his
translator by waking me right now I get
he's saying when he's saying fat one's a
measurement like oh six feet tall right
and then that's all no and he also meant
like Oh like like this is what my eyes
are seeing it's one girl and then as
she's moving in video this is another
girl it's not the same yeah I got no
tech so so this is what happens I'm
surprised right and I'm like oh she's
fat as [ __ ] so that's what comes out of
my mouth
I just want to say I think this is
wonderful in what she's doing is right I
agree a hundred percent I think young
woman I love if she's using her platform
for positive and I'd love that she's not
shying away from whatever mental health
issues action I just feel bad for
whoever's dating her why cause she's an
artist and she's bipolar
that must be hard to do
gonna say because she's fat we just
healed the wound maybe some shitty
stitches he'll try to drag other people
with you well what'd you say what'd you
say people people that are bipolar
aren't fun to be with I guess what I'm
trying to say is that's nice that she's
beautiful on the inside and then because
when she has the condition she doesn't
let it like like destroy her now she
tries to empower other people with
conditions dude seriously in all
seriousness I think it's really don't
what she's doing because I haven't heard
of any other celebrities that do that
like what exactly they are the way that
she's doing it here cuz she's lightening
up the whole situation and like people
aren't gonna go and see her and they're
gonna get inspired by her so if she's
pushy something really positive that she
wants to make mental health something as
like try to change the stigma behind it
because they want they want people to
view this kind of like taking care of
your body like going to the gym I could
appreciate this because when I was in
college I was actually part of a mental
health organization and at that time we
didn't have any fun people like her it
was like some boring ass [ __ ] and I'm
Monica Rogers and [ __ ] well I'm not say
this in any other way but like they'll
bring like people that look pretty
[ __ ] up like we have they're bulimic
whatever and they're trying to give like
there's some serious speech and then it
just brings it down and you don't really
it's just depressing
yeah you can't you want an inspirational
like successful artist that's like oh
well this person probably got it all and
then like they're like wait a minute
Demi Lovato you have bipolar like me too
and then and you start relating if we do
have a bipolar rock concert yeah you're
gonna attract way more people and happy
like some person telling like us that
story you have a bipolar hey guys I'm
ready to do a slow song now I hope
that's show with everybody okay
yeah I just want to see that concert
that be [ __ ] insane we have to pick
it so you were you gonna save me no I
need you to back me up right now say
something cool so no I agree with what
you're saying cuz it's like she's using
that platform to show like hey you might
have this condition or this disorder but
you can also be successful just like me
real quick I always have this question
when it comes to any charity thing or
whatever what exactly are these cats
doing like is it just because I just saw
a bunch of speakers and then everyone's
like dancing around in the montage okay
it's all grouped every so what cast is
it's a pretty much a rehab they they
take care of like wellness mental health
and addiction treatment center and so
she actually went there herself she was
a patient okay but then now like she's
come so far along cuz when she went into
cast she was she was like pretty much on
the border of like suicide like crazy I
mean she was a Disney star dude you
don't do yeah
just see she was former Disney star
crazy cocaine addiction and she would
self-harm she has bipolar she struggled
with bulimia how do all these Disney
people come out like this dude it's
crazy is there one that didn't what I
really think is that all these ailments
are actually the key to success and I
need me some of that yeah because look
at my one of my favorite actor slash
comedians Robin Williams
yes by Paul he was bipolar exactly and
he killed himself
I don't think I see I see these things
people see it as like Oh negative things
ICMS superpowers because if you can
experience their superpowers they're
like mutant superpowers because if you
could experience extreme happiness and
extreme sadness then you could
communicate those feelings to the public
and create awesome art but then the
burden is your heart hurts that's what
I'm saying like some of the best actors
are all [ __ ] insane yep your best
artists and they're all [ __ ] crazy I
need to be that I need me a little bit
yeah if you're just too normal and to to
like you're too mild you won't achieve
greatness so the so the thing is if you
do have a condition you could be great
yeah
now she's a co-owner of cast oh cool
yeah and so that's why she's gonna be
taking casts on her upcoming tour and
just offering group therapy Oh everyone
this is so awesome
no I I save I think to be serious I
think we should spread the word and make
it like normal and not taboo because if
when I was growing up it was like you're
crazy and I'm like oh well [ __ ] I
better I better just learn to own it
instead of being ashamed of it and I'm
like well whatever I never got treated
or went to a hospital or anything like
that but I probably should have
I think everyone's you do like you know
take care of their their mental health
just the same as I take care of my
physical health so how's your brain
you're pretty you're pretty were sharp
and everything that's true like take
care of this bill least that hey what do
you say so so meanly bullying
[Music]